events at the at the end of the day is
an accelerator of business
and a human connection and
alona thank you so much for joining me
on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great thank you very much for
inviting me i see you in your makeshift
office
in the heart of new york quarantine
honestly i wish i was uh back at the
office so at least i have a zoom
background to help me
feel as if i'm in the office but we're
all working from home at the moment
definitely definitely how is it going in
new york right now actually
new york feels a bit uh strange honestly
you walk into the streets
there are people in the streets but the
broadway is completely empty all of the
stores
are shut a little bit sad
and i bet it's a it's even more a little
bit sad when you're when you're running
and you're you helped found an event
management sas platform
when i'm assuming that there aren't too
many events taking place right now
right you are right that when it all
started
early march um as a company
visible as you mentioned is an event
success platform like
every good startup we've had our uh
roller coaster
across the universe and when that thing
hit us
i looked at my co-founder they were like
that's going to be a good chapter
how do we deal with that one that it's
not even legal to run events
and we we took a decision very very fast
that
people want to see each other want to
meet
events at the at the end of the day is
an accelerator of business
and of a human connection and if people
do not have a way to meet
in person they're gonna find the next
best way which is to meet almost in
person
over the virtual space so we decided
within two weeks to launch
um a virtual event platform in a way to
adjust our
our events management platform into a
virtual event management platform
so the first two weeks were tons of
uncertainty
unknowns people thought that in our
event software industry is going down
but i can tell you now we are um
six weeks uh in and
we've had the best month ever in terms
of demand and sales really
and so once we're actually uh these are
business-wise these are good times
okay so you went from being a company
that is now existential in the sense
that
you don't know when it's going to be the
next legal event and you're
turning it around to creating to to
pivoting and adapting to the situation
and having
one of the best months of the company
what is event success
platform in general what does that even
mean
so events are and when i say events i
mean professional events we're talking
about conferences
uh mutual summits and and so on not not
my birthday party
exactly not your abominations one day it
will be professional as well i'm telling
you
probably so events are very complicated
yeah having said that are very
meaningful for business
uh 24 of marketing budgets
of an average b2b organization is being
invested
at events but um operationally wise
and complicated very difficult to
measure
very difficult to demonstrate the value
although everyone is doing it
yeah we in a way a couple of years back
we started with
having a networking solution for events
because we thought everyone is coming to
network but then we discovered that
the needs are much much bigger than that
and we've built
a holistic all-in-one solution
that is not just helping you to manage
an event but is helping you to run a
more successful event
i know that you've been involved in
several events in the past i read that i
think you organized some events so you
know how complicated it is i know the
the blood sweat and tears that is being
put into these things yeah
so in a single platform we offer
everything from creating the event
website
to promote the event to selling tickets
and managing registration to providing
a networking community for attendees um
and many other modules to help you
manage content and speakers
wonderful sponsors and so on and on top
of that there is a whole layer of
data and insights that helps you
take decisions that are based on data
and by that help you prove the impact of
those events on the bottom line
wow okay so so talk to me a little bit
about these these
data and insights that you're looking
for at events
uh what what matters to the event
organizers or what they're looking for
where's that added value over there
obviously it really depends on the type
of the event but let's talk about
i don't know an event of uh one of the
events of amazon
running an event on for aws developers
or for the ecosystem at the end of the
day
these organizations run events for a
reason usually it's a business reason
either to accelerate pipeline to create
new pipeline
to retain customers meaning make an
impact on retention
sometimes it's a brand play and we have
many kpis and depending on your specific
objective
we help you surface
those instances to really understand
okay how did the event
uh impact my bottom line or my pipeline
then you have beautiful dashboards and
stats
and because we are holistic we have data
from the attendees interaction
sponsored in the interaction audience
engagement
so there's a lot of data points that you
really need a holistic solution in order
to surface them to something that
an average marketer can actually
understand
okay that's that's interesting so how do
you actually adapt that to an
online event what does it mean to have
an online event and just
you know i'm a very good friend of mine
mickey he's he has a startup called
avian and he
he actually recently organized at the
otc the online travel conference with
about
3 500 participants and that was really
to me watching from the site as somebody
who organized quite a few conferences
and events
watching this amazing event unfold in
front of me with nobody having to print
out name tags nobody having to go and
put electricity across the
auditorium it was pretty crazy
it is so you know in addition to telling
mickey to use visible next time
um i don't think that uh here that
mickey
is unique about virtual events is that
yes costs
the production cost is way lower you do
not need a venue you do not need food
and so on having said that they are
complex if you want to run a couple of
thousands people event
the stream quality and to be able to
engage the audience
the alternative when you sit in a venue
you cannot really run that easily right
to to stand up in the middle and go you
can go to your phone that's true
but in the virtual conference the
alternative is a click away so you run a
very successful
virtual conference and to have an
engaged audience
and you can actually that that actually
provides
value not just it cannot be just a
webinar webinar most people today
i'm gonna watch the recording right a
real
event in the virtual space needs to have
all of the components of a successful
in-person events
some serendipity to be able to meet new
people
to have conversations to be inspired by
the content
sessions need to be shorter to keep you
engaged right
um the platform should enable you to do
multitasking
because that's a lost fight everyone is
multitasking so
let's just enable the attendees to
multitask around the event
um so there are many ingredients for uh
running a successful virtual event and
we're all learning it
as we go it's not like we've been um
virtual events were probably less than
half percent
of the total events in the world and now
they're probably 99 so
yeah i think we're huge i think it's
interesting because you know i'm also
looking at the classroom experience for
example now that i'm doing virtual
studies at stanford
it feels like a daily online conference
where we
gather around we have these i don't know
six classes that we're gonna go to and
we jump around from different rooms to
different speakers
networking with the students and it's
just difficult
to feel the urgency to be there in
person
when you have the recording two hours
later and i can sit down
at 11 p.m after i finish my work and i
can just sit down and relax and watch it
how do you actually so how do you
tangibly create this
the value of networking and the
serendipity and what you were touching
on
for for the real time being because at
the end it's so accessible it's it's
right around the corner
i just have to wait a few hours and
it'll be online
that's true i can tell you that we are
definitely not done and i do not think
that
we've cracked it uh we're on the right
track we see a lot of success but our
vision for
virtual events is very very big we
believe that once events will be back
and they will
because at the end of the day there is
nothing like it's it's true that virtual
events have
uh advantages but there is nothing like
shaking a hand and i actually am
optimistic i do think that people will
be back at shaking hands that was the
next question
and uh you know to look someone in the
eye there's nothing like a face to face
having said that i do think that um what
we see now
and the market education around virtual
events will cause
the hybrid events category derives
meaning that
every live event will have a virtual
track
in a way interesting so a new category
will will emerge
out of this uh out of this crisis in my
mind
and to to have people actually join live
is only by
again helping them connect with other
people
having conversations something that you
can just not get in the recording
and that's that's the thing to crack
totally totally along
i'd love to hear a little bit about
yourself so you you've seen visible grow
from from 10 employees to 130
as you move to new york where do you
come from how do you even
get to visible and and where does all
this passion lie within you
um i uh i met my two co-founders
actually in a
idc which is a private university in
israel we all got accepted to the zeal
entrepreneurship program
wonderful i just i just had a session
with liat erinson the other day
send them my regards one of my favorite
people um
and the three of us had an amazing click
honestly from day one we all came from
many many years in the israeli air force
and kind of like we're raised on very
very similar values
um after we graduated we moved on to
part-time jobs and started working like
twice a day behind my parents backyard
um a small place 20 minutes outside of
tel aviv
and
we're very passionate about doing
something related to connecting people
at events over the years after almost a
year and a half
i moved to new york when we were still
10 people without any product market fit
without revenue without anything and had
the opportunity of building our
go to market teams the sales team the
marketing team the customers
customer success team and so on wow so
led um very interesting pivot we started
as a mobile networking app and kind of
like expanded to this event
success platform after we started the
markets has just a huge need to it
and personally uh i have two amazing
young kids no i'm in dunny i'm three
years old in a year and a half
married to tal um wonderful
i was in the air force for so many years
and uh very passionate about
amazing teamwork um being surrounded by
very smart capable people and we love
challenges so
actually we're enjoying this time
because it's a very very challenging
time
um very sad time as well but
business-wise
we challenges are making us stronger and
um we believe that um
we were able we have a team who
who's shining when it's difficult right
so i mean everybody obviously is working
on
is working online you have i mean it's a
big company now it's not like a small
startup in the backyard you have over
100 people working
full-time on this you're your leader
your co-founder
you're one of the chief somethings and
how do you go and
lead a team the day that this thing hits
and not only lead any regular star but
you're leading a startup that is
directly affected by the executive order
of shutting down events
so how do you go and rationalize that to
over a hundred employees who are now
saying well
i don't know if this i don't know if we
should be here
that that that is a really good question
and i think we were very very lucky to
have a very strong
company culture and set of values that
our people really believe in
and when when it hit we had to really
over communicate
and be very transparent on what our
plans are
on why we believe that um there's a huge
opportunity ahead of us if we
move fast if we become a speed boat if
we go back
to the garage days and thinking like a
10 people start up
wow and we're able to rally the troops
around us
and um be very agile
and i think understanding that working
from home is
not like being in the office and you
need to be in front of your people
on zoom to be very communicative
to really recognize and be empathetic to
your people
because everyone is going through
difficult times yeah um
well in new york some people are with
their roommates in a very small room
without great conditions to work and
they need that
motivation boost once a day and to know
that someone's thinking about them
someone takes care of them and you know
we do all kinds of things like virtual
happy hours
we send uh gifts to people's homes and
uh uber eats coupons
and virtual magalita classes and all
kinds of cool things to make them feel
better
in new york uh you know i'm i'm working
remotely at a startup
an amazing startup here in palo alto so
we have a lot of these
a lot of the similar things that you
mentioned but i think one thing that you
do have that we don't have is that
probably every person
that works in invisible new york is at
least one connection away from somebody
who has coveted
and i think and i'm and i'm sure that
that has an even
more it raises even more adversity
than you know we're just saying saying
yes a few of us are
directly affected but really we're just
a part of this whole big arena
new york is really the heart and when he
knows somebody that has it
all of a sudden i think the world can
turn upside down and i can tell you
more than that we had several people in
the company who
who had it and recovered and wow um
that all happened while we were pivoting
so again that was uh even made it even
more interesting
do you take over a hundred people and
you've pivoted the whole boat
or do you take just the people that are
sitting on the deck
and saying you guys we have a secret
plan i want you guys to go
right and and let's just see what this
goes
did had uh we we were very fast to
understand that we need to create some
sort of a task force
who would be able to to lead the boat
together with the leadership team so we
did appoint
a virtual task force um
and they were that they were in charge
of really
responding very fast to the market and
constantly enabling and educating the
rest of the team so
it was a very very structured process
but everyone needs to be involved
and obviously you need to have people
who can take decisions because a hundred
people cannot take decisions uh
at the same time so we did have a task
force uh we met with our leadership
team more often with our board more
often to enable us to move fast
definitely so give me a little bit of
context as of
i don't know let's say january of 2020
uh wha
what what is happening with bixabo in
the event management
world so how i mean do you how many
events are you doing
and what type of your private company so
maybe you can't disclose that but sure
but i'd like to get a little bit of
sense of what visible is like
well i can tell you that the first week
of march where
all of the uh you know techcrunch and
everyone kept publish
publishing that um that event got
cancelled and data had gone cancelled
we opened our dashboard and saw that we
have around
thousand events uh planned on the
platform
in the next three months and day by day
day by day we got uh with another
announcement or got another email
canceled cancelled cancelled cancelled
um
wow so from being you know in a vervis
a successful quarter with some of our
biggest clients planned this is event
season by the way so
all of the top technology conferences or
our customers are just
cancelled in a speedy um
period so that was uh challenging as as
you can imagine and obviously tons of
uncertainty a lot of stress
among our employees of okay what will we
do if all our events are cancelled
totally totally okay alone we have just
about two minutes left but i'd love to
know
give me give me some piece of advice
that you would give to a rising
entrepreneur
you went through possibly the one of the
hardest adversities that a startup can
go through
essentially shutting down the shelters
and within a day and saying okay
good luck even though you're a
successful 130 people company
haha here's a here's a twist uh
what what is like one advice to a rising
entrepreneur who's gonna go through a
lot of adversities
and and you just put into a really major
one
i think to stay agile open-minded
watch the door that we're not going to
get into that definition now but
it's key and to honestly to
to stay cool and not give up
that's uh if you if you work for it if
you dare
it again optimistic it will come
it's it's in your hands oh definitely
and i think it's it's all about the
reaction
and you know just like you came out the
other end even more successful
i think for every startup that does this
you have nine or 99 startups
who are saying okay let's just wait it
out and hope that we make it by the end
uh so i definitely think it's this
resilience and this godol
and um and i definitely definitely see
it
alone right before we finish i have to
ask you the hardest question
i'd love to know three words that you
would best describe yourself as
probably the first one is a family
um i have to be surrounded by family my
own family and the visible family
and uh one is uh
[Music]
i mentioned that before but uh optimism
yeah
and i guess the third word would that
have been would this would have been
there in january if we had this
interview back then
if if we had one sorry if we had the
interview back in january would optimism
still be
in your top three i i
yes oh yes that's my wife my mom
nice they they would use that uh the
descriptive word always
and um the third one is probably uh i
don't know level-headed
stains staying cool i love it and i'll
add rose gold at the end
all right alon thank you so much for the
time i really appreciate it
and best of luck with everything that
you're doing it sounds it sounds
pretty amazing even in the hardest of
times
thank you very much good luck to you as
well enjoy enjoy stanford
thank you